a Civil Air Patrol as a fella I guess
some kind of a spokesman Mark wutan gone
viral on Tick Tock to insist national
service stop hiring middle-aged white
dudes stop hiring middle-aged white
people especially dudes they're Pilots
because honestly we all think alike too
much and if we're going to be preaching
diversity and being inclusive and For
Crying Out Loud Let's back it up with uh
you know let's make the rhetoric meet
the reality could you knowing that the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff is
more concerned with fighting white rage
and indoctrinating the cadets and the
troops into woke ideology anti-white
ideology anti-male ideology could you
seriously say oh yes the best path for
you son is to join the military